Speaker 1: And those close to him have a reason
to tell his version of the story.
He has been widely seen as a Trump lackey
who politicized the Justice Department.
But when the big moment came after the election,
he defied the president, who expected to do
his bidding.
This language of Mike Pence defied Trump on
January 6th.
Then he didn't do well.
What right.
William Barr defied Trump.
It may be in some really narrow sense, accurate
that they didn't do the thing Trump wanted
them to do, but they didn't really have a
choice.
Mike Pence can't stop the election from going
forward.
And Joe Biden from becoming president of the
United States must Trump might think Pence
could have done that, but Pence couldn't do
that and much the same way in any real sense.
I mean, Barr could have attempted things which
would have violated all sorts of law and the
way that elections are run.
But in reality, the defiance that we saw from
William Barr was just although he can't get
involved, there's nothing that he can actually
do.
And the article goes on to say, Barr's betrayal.
This is amazing.
Barr's betrayal came on December one over
lunch in the attorney general's private dining
room with Michael Balsamo, a Justice Department
beat reporter at the AP.
Also in attendance were the DOJ chief of staff,
Will Levie, and spokesperson Carrie Copeck
Balsamo was not told the reason for the invitation.
When Barr dropped his bombshell between bites
of salad, he mumbled and Bylsma wasn't sure
that he had caught what attorney general had
said just to be general, Balsamo said.
Are you saying, sir, I think you better repeat
what you just said, Koushik interjected.
Barr repeated.
To date, we have not seen fraud on a scale
that could have affected a different outcome
in the election.
This time, Balsamo heard him.
Balsamo story appeared on the AP Newswire
shortly after lunch, disputing Donald Trump's
persistent, baseless claims.
Attorney General William Barr declared Tuesday
the US Justice Department had uncovered no
evidence of widespread voter fraud that could
change the outcome of the 20 20 election once
this report.
Went public, Donald Trump went absolutely
and completely insane, and now, of course,
Trump has a full and complete meltdown.
This happened a couple of days ago while we
were on our vacation.
A statement by Donald J. Trump.
Look at this.
Look at how quickly Trump turns on people.
RINO former attorney general Bill Barr failed
to investigate election fraud.
Now, that's untrue, even though it's unclear
Barr should have been involved in looking
into it.
Barr did look into it and he found no material,
materially significant fraud.
Trump goes on and really let down the American
people.
I would argue the American people are not
let down when democracy actually gets the
right, the person who won into office.
That's how democracy works.
Even the scam that took place in Georgia of
ballot stuffing on camera, he couldn't see
what was wrong with it.
Now, that's a completely bogus conspiracy.
It's been widely debunked, just like he failed
to understand the Horowitz report and let
everyone down with respect to getting a timely
investigation where Durham on all of the corruption
of the Obama Biden administration, he goes
on to say, and this is slightly off screen
for which I apologize.
It's people in authority like Bill Barr that
allow the crazed radical left to succeed.
He and other rhinos in the Republican Party
are being used in order to try to convince
people that the election was legitimate when
so many incredible facts now come out to show
conclusively that it wasn't.
None of that is true.
Trump fully melting down and now going after
William Barr even going further, Trump writing.
If he felt this way, why did Barr say he was
greatly honored and proud to have played a
role in the many successes and unprecedented
achievements you have delivered to the American
people?
In the final letter he wrote to me because
Barr as a politician and he's going out with
a completely standard, meaningless pseudo
suck up letter of no value whatsoever, he
said.
Few could have weathered these attacks, much
less forge ahead with a positive program for
the country.
William Barr may believe that and yet have
found no voter fraud.
These are not mutually exclusive things.
Trump also finishing this off by saying now
it was revealed that Barr was being pushed
to tell lies about the election by Mitch McConnell,
another beauty who is worried about damaging
the Republican chances in the Georgia runoff.
What really damage the Senate Republicans
was allowing their races to be rigged and
stolen.
And worse, the American people to no longer
believe their vote matters because spineless
rhinos like William Barr and Mitch McConnell
did nothing.
Here is my message on this is crazy.
Out of this world stuff is just of almost
nothing he's saying is true.
He got William Barr's name right.
He got he correctly claimed there were runoffs
in Georgia.
That's true.
Everything else is lies as cartoonish as this
is.
Do not get complacent.
The midterms are starting essentially in three
months.
The midterm season starts.
Unless we want a repeat of Obama's 2010 situation,
we have to come out and vote.
Then there's twenty twenty four.
I already told you yesterday, a Trump twenty
twenty four ticket against Biden and or Kamala
Harris, I don't think looks particularly good.
And especially if Republicans have a strong
twenty twenty two midterm twenty twenty four.
Trump versus Biden or Trump versus Harris
scares me significantly.
Last thought on this.
Every time Trump supporters say we like Trump
because he just he's, he cares about America
and he's good for the country.
Look at these statements.
Look at these lies.
And there is he will say he will attack American
democracy in absolutely any way that he sees
advantageous to him.
He doesn't care about the country.
He certainly doesn't care about his supporters
and he cares about them and other people only
to the extent that they are politically useful
to him.
They're about to get useful again.
His supporters are about to get useful again
because he needs their money so that he can
play kingmaker in twenty twenty two.
I can't think of anything less patriotic and
Trump just melting down on anyone who simply
said, Mr. President, I wasn't able to find
any evidence that you actually won.
Those now become enemies and they now become
rhinos and unpatriotic or whatever the case
may be.
It's disgusting.
I can't think of anything less patriotic.
And we'll have more on this on our Instagram.
Make sure you're following us there at David
Pakman show